[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the Fourier series and in the last
couple of videos I showed you how to
compute these in that lab and in Python
and now what I'm going to show you is
what can go wrong
when you're using the Fourier series on
a discontinuous function so in the
previous video we approximated a
triangular hat function that was not
smooth but it was continuous there were
no jumps and the values now what we're
going to do is approximate a hat a top
hat function where the function jumps in
these two discontinuous points here okay
so the functions going along constant it
jumps to another constant value and then
it jumps back down back down to zero
okay so we're going to again code this
up in MATLAB really simple we're going
to have a domain from zero to ten
in this case it doesn't really matter
what your domain is we're just going to
do from zero to ten I think I've chosen
1024 points in in the middle of this so
it's a nice number divisible by four and
I'm going to define my function pretty
simply by setting it all equal to zero
and then taking the middle half and
setting it equal to one here okay and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
approximate I'm going to compute the
first hundred terms so not twenty here
now we're gonna compute the first
hundred terms in this Fourier series by
again just to remind you we're going to
compute these coefficients a K and B K
multiplying our cosine and sine modes by
taking the inner product of our function
with those cosine and sine modes and
because we're doing this in a computer
these are not analytic functions these
are vectors that have that are my
function evaluated at those 1024 points
from zero to ten okay so f is a vector
and then I have a cosine vector and a
sine vector and I'm literally computing
their dot product here at the sum of F
dotted with that other vector that's the
dot product and I have to normalize by
the length by 2 over L and by my Delta X
that I'm using to approximate this inner
product ok and so once I add up those
first hundred terms in my Fourier series
I'm gonna plot my original function and
my Fourier series okay so a pretty
simple thumb code and this is what you
get so you see that there are kind of
qualitatively the right features you
know the white top hat function is what
I want to approximate the red curve here
is my hundred mode Fourier series and
you can see that it gets the right
general behavior but around these
corners there's this really interesting
ringing phenomenon known as a Gibbs
phenomenon so this is really really
important you'll see this all over the
place
this Gibbs phenomenon Gibbs is
phenomenon and essentially what it tells
you is that near points of discontinuity
your Fourier series if you ever truncate
it so if you added up all infinitely
many sines and cosines this would go
away in the limit as you know this one
hundred became infinity and I add up
infinitely many cosines and sines this
Gibbs phenomenon will in fact go away
but anytime I truncate my series for a
discontinuous function I'm gonna get
this this ringing Gibbs phenomenon so
I'm gonna get these kind of oscillating
artifacts at the points of discontinuity
okay and the reason is is because these
discontinuous points so the sine and
cosine functions are smooth they're
they're smooth functions they don't have
any discontinuities and so the only way
I can truly build this discontinuity
this this jump is by adding up sines and
cosines of all frequencies in just the
right proportion so that they stack up
to form this perfectly sharp Ridge and
if I drop even a few of those terms at
the end I'll get this this ringing
because they're not perfectly cancelling
out to form that steep that steep cliff
okay so that's Gibbs phenomenon you see
this all the time in numerix you'll
you'll you'll see it now that you know
it's there in in numeric sometimes
you'll see this ringing because you're
approximating these discontinuous
functions with a truncated Fourier
series okay so important to know about
something you'll see is that if you
increase this number from one to a
hundred if you increase this to
something like n over
to where n was the number of grid points
I have so let's say I add up 512 of
these in this case I actually do a
really nice job so if you if you're
approximating your function on a
discrete domain with n points now you
can get away with adding up n over two
of these sines and cosines and you
finally get rid of that that Gibbs
phenomenon so this is closely related to
the fast Fourier transform and the
discrete Fourier transform which is how
you compute these on on vectors of data
efficiently and we'll talk more about
that that later but I just wanted to
point out that you know since my my data
vector F and my data vectors of cosine
and sine only had 1,024 points if I used
n over 2 modes I actually get a really
nice nice approximation on those
discrete points now here's the rub if I
doubled the resolution of my domain now
this approximation it actually has this
massive ringing happening it's just that
you can't see it we're only plotting
these kind of odd points where it
perfectly lines up and so we're not
actually plotting the peak points but if
I doubled the resolution of my domain
for example then you'd actually see that
between the points I'm plotting this
thing is still ringing quite badly ok so
it's really a dangerous phenomenon that
you have to be aware of is this this
Gibbs phenomenon
maybe I'll just run it back so that you
can see kind of what it looks like
and I thought this would be fun to
actually plot this as a movie so here
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
plot now for M equals 1 to 100 we're
gonna keep increasing the order and see
how the Gibbs phenomena gets worse and
worse okay so this is just a cool movie
you can download on our book website and
you can kind of see this Gibbs
phenomenon getting worse and worse or at
least getting more localized to the
corners as you increase the order of
your approximation okay so the first
mode is just you know kind of this bump
in the middle and then as you add and
add modes they're kind of cancelling out
to make it flatter and flatter on the
top but then that concentrates the
ringing in these these corner regions
okay really important property
interestingly you'll see this I'm gonna
do this example later remember I can I
can for you transform this triangular
hat function but if I use the Fourier
transform to approximate its derivative
which looks like this top hat function
I'll get Gibbs phenomenon in the
derivative okay so I'll show you that
later when we use Fourier transforms to
approximate solutions of partial
differential equations okay thank you